there's a roughly 91 billion dollars of
taxable income under reported each year
our goal is to look at that type of
thing by looking at how tax evasion
skenes change in relation to IRS
regulations and through this process our
goal is to anticipate new iterations of
abusive tax shelters or tax evasion
schemes what have you the government
knows that as soon as it changed the
regulations they know there's going to
come up a new tax evasion ski so for
them the question is can we in some way
be one step ahead instead a one step
behind when it comes to finding tax
evaders our systems computer-aided law
in the past has been looking at task
behavior and trying to look for similar
past behavior what they're not doing is
they're not looking for possible modes
of exploitation that exists that haven't
been seen yet so what we're doing is
essentially acting as a tax evader that
is working on the government side almost
like an undercover agent we're saying if
we were somebody that had a very strong
incentive to evade tax to order to
iterate through the current system of
laws in order to generate tax savings
what would we do computer science can
offer a lot too low in a sense because
you can you can see the law says if you
do this then this happens else this
happens so it's quite amenable all these
human regulations to try to write them
in a source code we're trying to
represent what's written in the tax law
in a software one way to describe it
bluntly to say we have a calculator for
tax we use this calculator to do
simulations as in saying we put in
different inputs of a transaction and
then see what is our tax output then we
can see if we can optimize it so that's
where we're saying this is how we find
these transactions sequences that will
pay the least amount of tax it's not
that far-fetched to think as some people
say the lowest code and then trying to
figure out how can you from a computer
science perspective
prove this essential document of
civilization as you could describe the
lower to be